in this lesson you're going to learn how
to find the reference angle when you're
given an angle in degrees or in radians
and we're going to talk about the
formulas that you can use to find that
reference angle so first let's do some
problems with degrees and then we'll do
some problems with radians so with
degrees what you want to do is when
you're working with an angle it's kind
of like a spinner right like if you spin
it this direction that's a positive
angle if you spin it clockwise that's
actually a negative angle but just say
for example here we're gonna spin it
counterclockwise if we spin it and you
end up in this first quadrant the
reference angle is just theta whatever
the angle is that they give you if you
end up over here in the second quadrant
you can take 180 minus the angle to get
your reference angle or if it's in
radians you do PI which is the same as
180 minus the angle if you're in the
third quadrant over here and you just do
the angle minus 180 or if you're in
radians you do the angle minus PI and
then if you end up in the fourth
quadrant you do 360 minus the angle or
two pi minus theta now if you don't want
to use the formulas what you can do is
wherever you end up like you know with
the spinner you spin it it can go around
as many times as you want on either
direction wherever you end up that's
called the terminal ray you always want
to drop an perpendicular to the x-axis
then you look at that angle that's
formed between the terminal ray and the
x-axis that's your reference angle it's
always between 0 and 90 if you're in
degrees or 0 and PI over 2 and you're if
you're in radians and it's always
positive so for example if I was ending
up here in the 3rd quadrant I drop my
perpendicular to the x-axis like that
and then that would be a reference angle
if you're over here you'd go up to the
x-axis and that would be a reference
angle so let's go through some examples
I think you'll get a better feel for
this say for example 120 120 we start
here it's positive so we're gonna spin
counterclockwise 90 a little bit more is
120 so what I could do is I could drop a
perpendicular and say how many more
degrees does it take me to get to that
x-axis that's going to be 60 degrees
notice this is in between 0 and 90 it's
positive that's our reference angle or
you could say well I'm in the second
quadrant let me just do 180
- the angle 180 minus 120 is 60 so you
can either use the formula or you can
just do a little bit more intuitively by
drawing a sketch that's what I like to
do for number two let's look at 600 600
is kind of interesting because 360 plus
another 180 that's how much 540 plus
another 60 is going to put you at 600
right so what we did is we went all the
way around and a little bit more right
but when we drop that perpendicular to
the x-axis that angle between the
terminal ray and the x-axis was a 60
degree angle now another way to do this
is you could say let's just subtract 360
from 600 so 600 minus 360 is 240 degrees
240 degrees is here in the third
quadrant right so if we take our angle -
180 240 - 180 is 60 degrees so you can
use the formula but these formulas only
really work when it's a positive angle
and it's in between 0 and 360 or 0 and
2pi so the third example I actually gave
us a negative angle negative a hundred
so that means we're actually gonna be
going what clockwise this time so we're
gonna go 90 + 10 more put you at
negative 100 if we drop a perpendicular
how many more degrees does it take to
get to the x-axis that's going to be 80
degrees not negative 80 because remember
the reference angle is always positive
always between 0 and 90 if you're
working in degrees but if you don't like
that method and you prefer the formulas
you could just say well I'm gonna add
360 adding 360 or subtracting 360 that's
just like going around you know one
direction or the other a full revolution
you're gonna end up in the same spot
that terminal ray so it's going to be
the same reference angle see here at 240
right and we're in the third quadrant so
again we could say theta minus 180 240
minus 180 is oh I made a mistake here
this is 260 degrees so we've got 260
minus 180 which is 80 degrees and you
can see that that's going to be your
reference angle so same idea now let's
do some in rate
okay number four we have 11 PI over six
sometimes what I like to do is when it's
improper like this how the numerator is
greater than the denominator is I like
to convert it into a mixed number so 6
goes into 11 once with 5 left over so
this is like one in 5/6 pi 1 pi we know
is 180 degrees right plus another 5 6 pi
right so almost 5 6 5 6 of pi is almost
on another 180 degrees so that puts us
right about here now if we drop it
perpendicular to that x-axis how much
more did it take to get to that x-axis
that's 1/6 pi all right so that's going
to be PI over 6 which is our reference
angle now if you want to use the formula
you can say well we're here in the
fourth quadrant we're in radians we
could take two pi minus theta so we can
say 2 pi minus our angle which is 11 PI
over 6 now 2 is like 2 over 1 if I
multiply the numerator and denominator
by 6 that's 12 PI over 6 minus 11 PI
over 6 which is 1 PI over 6 so you see
you're getting the same thing 1 is just
like more intuitive where you draw the
sketch let's look at number 5 now this
one's interesting because it's a
negative angle 8 over 3 that's improper
that's like negative 2 and 2/3 pi right
so negative angle we're going clockwise
negative 1 pi negative 2 pi and 2/3 of
Pi which you're right about there if we
drop a perpendicular to the x-axis it
takes another 1/3 pi right so our
reference angle is PI over 3 remember
it's always positive when you do the
reference angle even though this was a
negative angle the reference angle is
positive between 0 and PI over 2 PI over
2 is 90 but so between 0 and 90 degrees
there on PI over 2 in radians but if you
don't like that method you can see we
went around more than one revolution
right so what I could do is I could say
well negative 8 PI over 3 I want to make
this into a positive angle so let's just
say I add 2 pi ok 2 pi if I multiply the
numerator denominator by 3 that's 6 PI
over 3 plus negative 8 PI over 3 that's
a negative 2 PI over 3 it's still a
negative angle let me add
other revolution another 2pi so that's
really like adding six PI over three
plus negative 2 PI over 3 that's 4 PI
over 3 which is like 1 in 1/3 pi right
which makes sense see 1 and 1/3 pi but
if we're using our formulas now you can
see we're in the third quadrant and
we're in radians so theta minus PI
that's going to be our angle 4/3 PI or 4
PI over 3 minus PI which is like PI over
1 if we multiply the numerator and
denominator by 3 that's like 3 PI over 3
4 PI over 3 minus 3 PI over 3 is 1 PI
over 3 which is PI over 3 that's the
same thing we got here so you can use
the formula or draw a sketch number 6
the last one here 9 PI over 15
see 9 15 is what well 9 is a little bit
more than half of 15 right so that means
it's going to be a little bit more than
halfway to PI so it's going to be
somewhere right around here in the
second quadrant so we could say how much
much more does it take to get to 2 pi
here to the x-axis well that would be
another 6 PI over 15 which reduces to 2
PI over 5 so that would be our reference
angle just drawing a sketch but because
we're in the second quadrant we could
use the formula pi minus theta so pi
minus 9 PI over 15
pi is like PI over 1 if I multiply the
numerator denominator by 15 I get 15 PI
over 15 minus 9 PI over 15 which is 6 PI
over 15
which reduces to 2 PI over 5 and you
know you get the same result so either
draw a sketch or use the formulas and
you can find your reference angle now
what do we use reference angles for well
they're really handy when you're going
to find values of trig functions on the
unit circle and I talked about mastering
unit circle in that video right there so
follow me over that video and we'll get
some more practice with reference angles
as well as using the unit circle